Abrams: Well, good afternoon,
and thank you for coming.
Uh, I really appreciate you
taking the time.
Uh, so I'm curious--how many--
we have Android and App Engine,
so the Android guys were
supposed to sit over here...
No, no. Seriously,
how many of you are And--
primarily Android developers?
Okay, and how many
are primarily App Engine?
Okay, so Android is winning
a little bit.
That's what we expected.
Okay, great.
Um, so I'm--I'm Brad Abrams.
I'm the product manager
for, uh,
the Cloud-based developer
tools that we have.
man: Turn the microphone on.
Abrams: Mic, mic...
Ducrohet: Mic? Yes.
Uh, I'm Xavier Ducrohet.
I'm the lead
for the developer tools
and SDK for Android
at Google.
So why are we here?
Well, a lot of you are mobile
developers, so that's good.
Uh, I've been at Android
for, like, four years,
so as you can expect,
I've had a lot of devices.
I started, you know, with--
way back before the G1,
I had a prototype--
actually, I had several of them.
Then I moved to several G1s
that had myTouch, Droid,
Nexus One, Nexus S,
and, well,
every time I get a new phone,
it's always the same story--
all my data that's
in the cloud, great,
it's directly on my new phone.
Otherwise, well,
I have to reinstall apps,
reinstall data, and it's really
a bad story for the users.
And now that there
are tablets--
and I heard that some of you
may have some tablets, too--
Um, you're going to want
to have your application
working on a tablet, and you
do something on your tablet
because you're at home
and you have it with you,
and then you go somewhere
where you only have your phone,
and you want to have
all your data seamlessly.
Abrams: Uh, and I'm, uh--
the reason why I'm here
is I've been a web developer
for a lot of years,
and I just love the web,
and one of the things
about the web I really like
is the stateless nature
of the web.
And once you've built a web app
in PHP or whatnot,
I can go use that app
from anywhere,
and my--my state carries,
and, uh,
some constraints of the web
made that possible.
And when I came to Google
about a year ago,
I just fell in love
with Android.
It's just a fantastic platform,
and I love--I love my phone,
but I was
a little bit disappointed
with some of the apps,
you know, like,
I bust through a certain level
of Angry Birds, and, you know,
on one device, and then I--
I can't--
I-I can't access that level
on another device.
And so I was--I was, uh,
not happy with that experience,
um, and so it was--it was around
the holidays, right?
Ducrohet: Yep.
Abrams: Um, that we--
Xavier and I and several others,
um, started talking about,
What could we do to make this
a better experience? So...
Ducrohet: All right,
so, um, now if you're coming
from the mobile
developer side,
uh, when you think about putting
a cloud component
into your application,
you're probably going to have
a lot of questions.
Uh, the first one is going to be
cloud equal datacenters,
you know,
dealing with machines, you know,
CPU cost, bandwidth cost,
and all of that,
and that's probably
a bit scary at first.
Then there's simply
coding for a cloud.
Um, if you're coding
for a small device,
you're probably
not used to coding
for hundreds of CPUs
at the same time.
Uh, and then there's
the question of security
and authentication,
both, you know,
making sure that your app
actually connects
to the, you know,
data of its user,
and, you know,
not another user,
and also from a user
perspective, on the phone,
you want the experience
to be really good.
Typing a password on a phone--
not so good.
Um, it's possible, but it's not
a great user experience.
And finally, one of the other
questions is purely practical--
you're coming from Android, uh,
you know Java, you know Eclipse,
are you going to have to learn
about new tools?
Abrams: You know, Xavier,
those are fantastic questions.
You know, I anticipated
you might have those questions.
Ducrohet: Huh, surprising.
Abrams: So, uh, obviously there
are a lot of solutions out there
for building cloud-based apps,
and from an Android
ecosystem perspective,
use whatever, um,
solution you think makes sense.
Uh, we're gonna talk a little
bit about App Engine today,
uh, and App Engine, just to
address a lot of those points,
from a cost perspective,
App Engine is absolutely free
to get started,
so just like Android is free,
App Engine is free,
and you can go build the app
that we're gonna build onstage
for free today with App Engine.
And then your costs scale
with your--with your usage,
so as you have an app
that's amazingly popular,
uh, you know App Engine
can keep up with that,
uh, and the costs will be
linear with that.
Um, and so this--
we built App Engine
in--on top of Google scale,
so we built it to run
Google services,
uh, so the datastore
that I'll be using in the demo
is built on the same technology
that the index use--
that Google's index uses,
that GMAIL uses it.
So it is a highly scalable,
highly available system.
Um, and then one point
that I think is very important
is that from
a security perspective,
we've built App Engine,
as well as Android,
to have a really good
first-class notion
of the Google authentication
and Google identification,
and that helps tremendously when
you build out the applications.
And in terms
of ease of use, well,
we have the Google plugin
for Eclipse, um...
How many people have already
used the Google plugin
for Eclipse before?
Okay, yeah, so a good
number of you,
so I don't have to tell you,
it's--a few of you that haven't,
um, it's a fantastic, uh,
Java-based
development experience
for building
App Engine applications,
so whether they're
backed by GWT or not,
you can use them for Java-based
App Engine applications.
There's a local development
time server in it
that lets you debug, uh,
and build applications locally.
Uh, there's functionality
to push to production,
uh, to App Engine,
and you get--
somebody was asking earlier
about Google APIs--
in the latest version of
the Google plugin for Eclipse.
There's very easy access to
the whole range of Google APIs,
so we make it easy to discover
and use those APIs.
Um, and then we just added
a visual drag and drop designer
for building the client side--
the GWT client side
of those apps,
uh, which we'll show you
a little bit about.
And then it's--
it's really widely used
for App Engine development.
Ducrohet: All right,
that sounds excellent.
So let's build an app, uh...
Abrams: Yeah, what would you
like that app to look like?
What do you think
the architecture should be?
Ducrohet: So you're going to
want a cloud back end, right?
That's why you're here.
So you want to have
an App Engine component
with the storage,
uh, so let's--
well, that's a pretty simple--
you know, basic, simple--
let's make a task application.
Abrams: Y-you know who needs
a task-tracking app?
Ducrohet: Who?
Abrams: You know, uh, Larry Page
just got a new job.
He's our--he's our new C.E.O.,
and as C.E.O., you know,
he's got a lot
to keep up with nowadays.
Ducrohet: That's true.
Abrams: So I think maybe
as our sort of gift to Larry,
uh, we should--we should
build him a task-tracking app.
What do you think?
Ducrohet: All right,
Let's do that.
Yes, that's a good idea.
Abrams: All right, all right.
Ducrohet: All right,
so all tasks--so we're going
to have that App Engine server,
where we--
we will store those tasks,
and then we'll have
two clients.
One of them will be, uh,
an Android client, of course,
and then the other one
will be a web client
built with, uh, GWT.
Um, so...
You know, the other thing
that we want to do
is that we want
this Android application
to be a really good citizen.
Now we have a technology
in Android called C2DM.
It's Cloud to Device Messaging,
and it's a way for the, uh,
server to notify
your application
in a very efficient way.
You don't want your
Android application
to regularly go and talk
to the server, saying,
"Hey, did something happen?
What about now,
did something happen again?"
It's like, you just want to wait
for the server to tell you
something happened,
you know, talk to me again,
and then, you know, you do
actually exchange some data.
So this is the C2DM service.
Um, it basically opens
a connection,
and you have
one single connection
that is shared by every
C2DM-enabled application,
so it's much better, uh,
not having every application
every now and then
waking up the device,
and then the device
goes back to sleep,
and then ten minutes later,
another application wakes it up,
so C2DM
is much better.
So what we see here
in that diagram
is that we have
a lot of components
that are already handled
by the current tools.
Uh, App Engine server
and the web client--
it's handled by GP
that Brad just talked about.
Uh, on the top left,
we have the Android client,
which is handled by the tools
that my team is responsible for,
the Android developer tool--
the ADT plugin.
And in the middle,
there's those arrows there
that are going to be some sort
of network communication,
and I don't know anything
about those.
Abrams: Yeah, those arrows--
those arrows on the diagram
seem to be the hard part,
but as Xav said, the other
pieces are sort of taken care of
by other tools,
but it's really integrating
these pieces that's hard.
So, um, I'm happy to announce
that we have a Beta release--
we just posted it a few hours
ago--where's Chris?
Yes--um, a Beta of GP 2.4,
and it's got built-in support
for Android in particular.
Uh, the RPC, uh, the Android
to App Engine line,
uh, we've got built-in support
for that,
and we've got
seamless integration
of Cloud to Device Messaging,
and those bits are available
for you today.
Uh, you can go to that URL
and download them right now,
uh, during the talk,
assuming the WiFi holds out.
[laughter]
Abrams: So, um,
So I--but, you know,
there's really,
I think probably the best way
is to kind of show a demo,
huh, you think?
Ducrohet: Yeah,
let's just build an app.
Abrams: Yeah, so, uh,
do you want to switch over?
Ducrohet: Yes.
Abrams: Okay, so what I--
we're gonna spend the bulk
of the rest of the time here
in actual code, in Eclipse,
and this is the Eclipse Helios
release--the latest release.
Uh, I have the latest Android
development tools installed,
and I have, uh,
this Beta version of GPE,
uh, which I'll mention is quite
hot off the presses,
um, so we thought
about showing--
well, we'll just kind of
do slides or something--
but I thought, no, no, no--
the I/O audience--
they want to see
the raw bits, right?
They want to see,
no matter how new they are,
and they will forgive me if...
[laughter]
Abrams: Okay,
anyway, let's press on.
Um, so we'll come in,
and we'll say, "File, New,"
um, and we'll create--there's
a new menu option under Android
called the, um, "App Engine
Connected Android Application."
Um, and we'll call our app
"Cloud Tasks,"
to build that task-tracking app
for Larry Page.
And what it's gonna do
is it--
you'll see, it creates--
Whoa, that didn't work out.
It creates two projects--
uh, an Android application,
and an App Engine application,
um, and it's just building
those right now.
Um, it will work out.
And--and they are connected.
They're tied in a couple of--
in a couple of places.
So first, we'll just come in,
um, and say, "Debug As,"
and then we're gonna
select this new item,
called "Local App Engine
Connected Application."
And I'm just gonna
spend a few minutes
showing you what you get
out of the box.
So just while
that's coming up, uh,
we'll come in here
and look at the source,
and you see in the server,
there's a couple of pieces here.
A couple of these files
are based on handling
the Cloud to Device Messaging,
um, functionality.
How many people
have--have checked out
Cloud to Device Messaging?
And how many people have
successfully gotten it to work
in your app?
Okay, okay, that's
a pretty good percentage.
Um, it--it's a very
powerful technology,
but it is tricky
to get it to work,
and everything you need to do
on your server.
Google just handles proxying,
um, uh, messages,
so you have to handle a lot
on your server.
And then there's this--
draw your attention to
this HelloWorldService,
and that's an RPC service
that we have,
and it--it just sends
the--the user's, uh, name.
Okay, so we should
have it up now.
The first thing we're gonna do
is go ahead and log in,
and many Android devices, um,
have Google, uh,
accounts already selected,
and we're gonna go ahead
and use, uh--
We've got Larry Page's account,
so we're gonna use that.
So I'm gonna go ahead
and log in,
and while that's happening,
I'll flip over
to the, uh, web app.
Um, so this is--
there's also a GWT--
that's a Google Web
Toolkit-based AJAX client,
uh, for the--
for the same service.
Ducrohet: I want to go back
to the Android for a minute.
As you saw, there's a concept
of account inside Android,
and so there's an API
to get the accounts,
and in that case,
that application just queries
for the Google type of account,
and we just display that
to the user.
You don't have to enter--to make
your user enter a password,
because, you know, when you
login the first time
on your phone, you entered
that password already,
so you don't have
to enter it again,
and that's the type
of experience
that I was, you know,
mentioning earlier. Um--
Abrams: That was fantastic.
Thank you for jumping in there.
Okay, so we'll log in
to the, um, client,
uh, and I--you know,
we need to log in as Larry Page.
Let's see, it's LarryPage20...
Ducrohet: 11, yes.
Abrams: 2011. I get that wrong.
Yeah, so 2011--
that was the year Larry
kind of ascended to the--
to the throne there.
Ducrohet: The throne, yes.
Abrams: Um, so we'll go ahead
and log in,
and notice that it just had me
enter the user I.D.,
because we're running
in App Engine test mode, right?
so we're running it locally.
When we deploy that, it's gonna
really ask us to log in,
and then we really will have
to get Larry's, uh, password.
So, um, let's see.
Uh, we get to log in here.
I had a little, um, snafu,
so let's log in again here.
And what you--what you should--
what's happening under
the covers when we log in
is it's actually doing
a register with C2DM,
so it's sending a message
from the emulator here, um,
through the--through
the internet to Google services,
and then back to, um,
back to the local
App Engine instance
we're running on this machine.
So you're seeing this machine--
the emulator talk to the local
App Engine on this instance.
And if I'm successful
registering,
you'll see a notification
right here
that says the registration
was successful.
So, um, that's kind of
the first thing.
Um, now--now that we're
logged in and successful--
I'll go ahead and clear that
so we don't get confused later.
Now I can click "Say Hello,"
and what that's gonna do
is an RPC call from the client,
uh, up to the server.
And what's really interesting
about this,
is notice what it says.
It says,
"Hello, Larry Page,"
because it knows who I am.
It knows
my Google authentication.
Because Android uses
Google authentication,
and App Engine uses
so they have
a shared notion.
And it's not like we're sending
name and password over the--
over the wire,
we're sending
some really large prime number,
or something, right?
Ducrohet: Yes.
Abrams: Okay, and, uh, and--
Ducrohet: Sort of.
Abrams: Uh, where is it?
In the web client, uh,
we have basically the same
experience on the web client,
so you can build one RPC layer
that works for your Android
client and your web client.
Um, and then we--
the other cool thing
we can do,
is we just have
this test screen--
2011, right? at GMAIL.
Whoops.
And we can say hi,
and basically,
as soon as I can send that,
it's successfully saying--
you see right up here,
and then there should be
the message--"Hi."
So that--what you get--
you get all of that just by
saying, "File, New, Experience."
So you already have
C2DM wired up,
and you already have an example
of an RPC service,
uh, up and going,
so you can go and clone that,
and see--really debug this thing
and understand how it works,
just by saying, "File, New."
But, you know,
I don't think Larry's
gonna be happy with just this.
Ducrohet: [chuckles]
Probably not, yes.
Abrams: We--we probably
need to keep going.
Ducrohet: Yes, yes.
Abrams: So let's keep going
a little bit, um,
and go ahead and flush out.
I'll start an ad--
I think when you build
a task-tracking app,
the first thing you need
is, well, a task,
and this is just a plain
Java object,
a couple of annotations on it
with due date,
but there's no, uh, persistent,
specific code in here.
This is just a plain old--
a plain old object,
and we're gonna use this, uh,
as our data transfer mechanism,
so it's just a plain class.
And then we're gonna show,
um....
Whoa, what am I doing?
We're gonna do--use our new
RPC tooling wizard,
and that's under
the Google, uh, node.
And now what we've done is we've
examined the server project,
and we've looked for--
looked at all the classes
that are in there
and found the ones
that are entities,
that are either marked with--
Uh, what's it called?
PersistenceCapable,
or, um,
whatever--
Serializable.
Anyway, uh, with a couple
of annotations, um,
that work for--
with our RPC layer,
and we found those, and then
when I click "Okay" here,
it's gonna create, um,
basically, query,
plus "create," "update,"
and "delete."
Uh, we looked at a bunch
of applications
with Android apps
and web apps,
and we found this to be
a very common pattern to do,
Uh, so let's just look at it
a little bit.
So basically, we have "create,"
"read," "update,"
"delete," and "query," um,
and then in addition
to that,
we have, into shared code,
um, we have generated
the appropriate client proxies,
the TaskProxy
and the request service,
that are the client version
to be able to call this.
So all the calling code
and the server code
was--was generated for you.
So, uh, and we'll drill into
exactly what those look like
in a little bit.
But, um, so now you can
do your data storage
however you want to.
You want to use Amazon S3,
you want to use
your own local database,
you have some local--some legacy
system that you're using,
you need to store data--
perfectly fine.
Do whatever you want.
Um, I'm gonna show you using
App Engines datastore.
It's a highly scalable,
NoSQL datastore,
um, and I'll just--
just to save the typing,
I'll just drag this file in,
um, and I'll show you bits
and pieces of that as we go.
So I'm just gonna create
DataStore--db,
new DataStore,
and let's see if it--oh, yeah,
and it needs to be static.
Whoa.
Okay, so now we have that.
Now let's look at how we
implement each one of these.
So query is just gonna be, um,
db.findall, and it--
it's instructive.
Let's look at what
that looks like.
So this is the implementation
of findall in that--
um, in that datastore class,
and all we're doing here
is this query.
We're using persistence manager
and doing a query,
and if you've done
SQL development,
it looks very similar
to you probably.
Um, what we're doing
is we're selecting from,
and the table is just the name
of the task,
uh, type that we put in,
because we store some
other stuff in this datastore.
Um, if you splunk
in the C2DM code,
you'll see we're storing
the C2DM registrations
in the same datastore,
so we need that, uh,
unique I.D. there.
Um, and then we're gonna
filter out--
we're only gonna
return those tasks
that match
the current user's I.D.
So, again, App Engine knows
who is making this request,
so it's gonna return
only those tasks
that match the I.D.
of the person
who's making the request.
So for example,
uh, Larry Page
may not want you
to see all of his tasks,
so that's kind of our--
our authentication mechanism.
And you notice
it's very basic,
and it--and it works, um,
for kind of large
data sets, too.
Ducrohet: So that's
what I would write
if I had, like,
hundred millions of users.
Abrams: Yes, yeah, so we--
I mean, obviously,
we're only gonna have a couple
of users here today with this,
but this exact pattern,
we have, uh,
App Engine customers use--
storing hundreds of millions
of entities in the datastore
using code that looks
very much like this,
um, same basic model.
So App Engine is really tuned
for this sort of experience.
Um, and then delete, um,
this is pretty basic.
We're just--
We're just gonna go ahead
and delete it.
I'm gonna do just a little bit
of business logic here,
get the user I.D.,
uh, out of the task
that's passed back
from the client,
um, and notice here
that I don't have to deal
with any serialization logic.
Like, I need to know what task
to delete, but it's fine--
like, the framework
handles all that for me.
Um, and this is where you could
do something like tombstoning,
or copy this data,
or do some permissions thing.
There's a place for
that business logic now.
Um, and then update is also
equally easy.
Uh, we're just gonna call
db.update of that item,
and that again, it just stores
the item in the datastore.
And the datastore handles
matching of the I.D.'s
to make sure they're right,
and then doing the update.
But, um, because we're
using the e-mail address
as a security precaution,
we want to make sure
that you can't put, uh,
something on Larry Page's
task list,
that you can only put things
on your own task list.
So no matter how the task
comes in,
we want to set, um,
the e-mail address--
oh, it was somewhere--
yeah, we want to set
the e-mail address
to the user's e-mail address.
So I'll just use
this utility function
to get the user's
e-mail address.
Um, and that's a really
powerful notion.
Notice that the--obviously,
the clients that Xavier and I
are gonna write
are gonna be well-behaved,
but this is just JSON
over HTTP,
so really, any client--
anybody could come
and try to hit the service,
so we need to do
some security here.
But notice how easy it was.
It was amazingly easy,
because App Engine and Android
share that common
authentication mechanism.
And just--
just to drive it home,
see how simple that "Get e-mail
address" method is?
Because App Engine already knows
the user who's logged in,
so we just have to pull
the e-mail address out of there.
Okay, so we'll, um,
go through and do "read" here.
Uh, and so the read
is just to show you
that you can, um, take
parameters to these methods.
And then "create" is--
is mildly interesting.
What we're gonna do
is actually do an update
of a new--a new task.
So what we're gonna do
is create a brand-new task,
send--round-trip that
to the datastore,
and that'll give it
a unique I.D.,
uh, in the datastore sense,
and then when we have
the unique I.D.,
when we later come
and update it,
we'll know which one--
which task we're updating.
So, you know, Xavier,
we've got an RPC layer here.
We've got a data layer.
I think we're ready for you
to build the Android app.
Ducrohet: Yes, well,
it looked a little bit too easy,
and, you know,
when I build my app,
I want to make sure that there's
at least some task in there,
so that I can make sure
that it works.
Abrams: Oh, I see. I see.
Ducrohet: So, uh, yeah.
Abrams: You don't trust me.
Ducrohet: Well... no.
Abrams: You think that I made
a bug here, and you don't want--
Ducrohet: No, no, it--
it just looks a bit too easy.
Abrams: That's okay,
that's okay.
I mean, there's a lot
of people here. I understand.
Ducrohet: Yes, yes. Exactly.
Abrams: So let me demonstrate
that it works.
I have this
client directory, too,
and it is where that
default GWT-based client,
uh, was created in.
And again, you don't
have to use GWT.
Um, uh, our team builds GWT. We
happen to think it's fantastic.
But you--you can use
whatever you want
and the system still--
still works.
So, um, I made some
small modifications
to the client, uh,
the same client that we saw.
Uh, and basically what I did
is implement buttons
for "create," "update,"
and "delete."
And I just want you to look
at the code really briefly
for, uh, each one of these.
So for "create,"
what we're gonna do
is call
that TaskRequest factory.
That was created by the serve--
by the RPC tooling wizard.
When I said I wanted task,
it created that in shared code.
Uh, and so we're able
to access this from--from GWT.
Um, and then we just do
an Asynchronous Fire
on, um, on this.
And notice that we're calling
the "createTask" method.
If we look back over here,
um, we should have, somewhere,
a create--a "createTask"--
there it is, "createTask,"
right there.
So there's a--there's
a one-to-one, um,
uh, correlation there.
And same thing with "update."
It looks exactly the same.
We're just gonna, uh,
pick a--
pick some task name
and put it in,
and then we call the update
task, passing that task.
And you see we're
doing it asynchronously,
so we don't block the browser,
um, thread.
And, of course, if you're
not familiar with GWT,
um, this is very cool in that
we get to write in Java code
the same language as our server,
same language
as our Android app,
uh, but it--it runs--
it compiles it to very
optimized JavaScript code,
which works in any web browser.
Um, so if I re--Oh, that's--
that would be the wrong--
that would be the finale that we
don't want to show people yet.
Okay, um,
let's reload this one.
Um, so, uh, there we go.
So there's our very nice
buttons that we added.
So I can come in
and create a new task,
um, and you see, it did
that round trip to the server
and gave me an I.D.,
and then I can update that task.
Uh, and you can see,
uh, Larry's first task--
Use "really big" blimps
for streetview.
I think that's--
that's a good idea.
Um, so we can create
another one,
and update that one, okay.
Uh,
let's do a couple more,
just to give you some test data.
[laughter]
Abrams: We spent most of our
time coming up with these items.
Ducrohet: [laughs] Yes.
Abrams: So I'm glad you like...
Okay, and there--
there's all of them.
So query--so "create,"
"update," "query work,"
um, and then we'll go through
and delete that last one,
just to show
that "delete" works.
Okay, so now what we've shown--
Ducrohet: Yes.
Abrams: I hope maybe
you're a little more confident.
Ducrohet: Yes.
Abrams: Now what we've shown
is a data layer on the server,
uh, an RPC layer there,
and then we showed
a very simple GWT client,
so you can probably--
you can probably maybe copy
some of that code for your
Android client, if you want.
Ducrohet: Uh, I could almost,
yes.
All right, so let's do
an Android application for that.
Uh, so Brad showed you
that there was two project
that were created--one for
App Engine and one for Android.
So let's take a quick look
to see what's there.
Um, there's a lot of classes,
actually, in there.
Uh, the main one, really,
that's going to be...
[speaking indistinctly]
the cloud task activity.
Uh, that's the one
that currently show
the "Say Hello" button,
or whatever.
The account activity
is the activity that you get
when you go to the account menu
to actually register
your account,
so it's there for you already.
But, you know,
if you don't like it,
if you want to style it,
you can just change that easily.
There's a C2DM receiver.
We'll talk about that later.
Um, and a bunch of--some utility
functions and things like that.
So to make my application, I'm
going to need some new files,
so I'm going to drop
a few files.
I'll show you what I drop,
so that, you know,
there's no, you know, hidden
things happening in there.
Uh, so mostly I'm going to drop,
first some resources,
there's, you know,
some icons, some styles,
some new themes
and things like that,
and some layouts here.
Uh, we're going to have
two new activities.
So the current one,
the main activity,
is going to be replaced by one
that display the list of tasks,
and, uh, so that will be
my task list layout here.
with the list item
to populate the list view.
And then I have
two other activities--
one to add a task, and one
to view the content of a task.
So I'm just going to drop that
into my project,
uh, and then I'm going
to drop some new code.
So, um, I said, you know,
new activities--
Okay, so I got
a disconnect here.
It's no matter. It's just that
the application is currently
being deployed, and we don't...
[speaking indistinctly]
Abrams: You should
really work...
[speaking indistinctly]
That would be good.
Ducrohet: Yes, I think I should.
Um, so we have those
two activities here--
a view task activity
and a task activity.
Uh, I'm going to need a new
custom application class,
um--so I'll explain why later--
and then after because, uh,
I'm going to use a list view,
so I have a list adapter
specifically for
my list of tasks,
and then I have an asynctask,
because you really never
want to do any, uh,
natural connection
on the UI thread,
so you should always use
an asynchronous mechanism,
and I'll explain to you later
why you need
actually that right now.
So I'm just going
to drop that here,
uh, there's some compilation
error, but that's no matter.
The final thing that
I want to drop is, um,
after, we're going to have
some sort of protocol
in the communication between
the client and the server,
uh, so we have some, um,
content in here
that I'm just going to drop
in that shared folder.
So Brad actually showed you
that folder earlier,
and it's there
on my client, too.
It's actually--
it's not just a cookie.
It's actually the same folder
that is used by both projects.
So when he created
the RPC layer,
uh, the TaskProxy was also
created for that project here,
and it's right there.
It's an interface that's
going to be created for you.
Um, you don't have to go
and do the same thing.
That's where the two projects
being linked together
is interesting.
So I drop that new, uh, class,
and then I'm going
to have to edit
my--my manifests in--
I did some components,
so I'm just going
to do that quickly.
Mm.
So the first thing
that I need is,
uh, on my
application node here,
I have a new class,
so I'm declaring it here,
and I have a custom theme,
so I'm just declaring it here.
And then, uh--
that's not what I want--
I have two new activities,
so you always need to declare
your activity,
even if they're not, you know,
they don't have...
[speaking indistinctly]
So I'm just doing
that here, too.
Okay, so the last thing
that we need to do
is really look at
that main, uh, activity.
And, uh, so cloud task activity.
So here, there's
a few things like--
there's a receiver here that you
don't really need to deal with.
It's there to deal with the, um,
when Brad created that account,
we got a notification
saying the C2DM
registration worked.
Well, it's that one here,
so if you want to change
the, um, the workflow,
you change that a little bit.
Now there's an onCreate here
that does--
basically that
HelloWorld content,
so I'm just going
to replace it with mine.
So, um, actually,
I'm going to start
by dropping a few fields
that I will use--use later.
And just drop them here.
Then, uh, I'm going to drop that
and explain what I'm doing.
Ducrohet: All right, so we're
going to remove that here.
So, um, I'm just doing
a new site content view
with my layout, um,
I'm having some, you know,
a listView object,
I have a progressBar object,
um, I have a task adapter,
which is my list adapter
from my listView
that I store in my task
application,
uh, for some reason,
and then I have my callback
from my listView,
uh, so I actually need
to make that, um, class--
implement that interface,
um, and that's about it.
And then there's this register,
which also, you know,
is registering the broadcast
receiver that we have above
to get the notification
from the C2DM registration.
And then, um, of course,
we unregister it,
in unDestroy.
And then, uh, we have
the menu creation,
and that UI here, that
we just don't need anymore,
so I'm just going
to delete it,
and instead I'm going to replace
it with all of that new code.
So, um,
it--it's a lot of,
you know, boilerplate
due to that demo,
the way it's built,
but the big thing here
is really in the onStart--
that's what I'm going
to show you right now.
Um, what I do here,
if the--yeah, there we go--
Uh, I just make sure that
the device is registered,
so as soon
as the activity launch,
if the device is registered
and I have a Google
account associated,
I'm just going to go and fetch
my task from the cloud,
and that method
is, uh, pretty basic.
You know, I display
the progress bar
to add some visual clue
for the user,
and then I create my asynctask,
and I just execute it.
And so that next task here
with a nice, you know,
"insert RPC command" here.
So let's implement that,
because that's really the part
that's complicated.
Normally, it's creating that--
that RPC.
So, um, we have this,
uh, RequestFactory
that's been created for you
by the RPC layer,
and it returns that TaskRequest,
which is also located
in the, um,
in the shared folder here,
and that's, you know,
what Brad showed you.
It's basically
that new interface
that has exactly the same method
as the server service
that you implemented.
The only difference is that,
you know,
instead of returning directly
the TaskProxy,
to return the request object,
which lets you actually
do the RPC code.
So we're going to do--
use that.
Of course, that's all
interfaces, and, you know,
you're probably wondering
how we're going to create those.
Uh, so what we do for you is,
there's a utility method here,
so, you know, it's not
hidden from anything.
It's just there.
You can go and look at it.
So we're going to use that.
So we're going to create
our RequestFactory first,
so, um...
There we go.
Ducrohet: And then there's
the getRequestFactory,
so it needs an--
um, an Android context,
and then the class
of the RequestFactory
that you actually
want to, um, associate.
All right, so let's look to see
exactly what that does for you.
Well, so first, there's that--
it just creates it for you.
That's, you know,
the hidden part.
Uh, the important part
is here.
It's actually going to look
for the authentication cookie
that was selected when the user
selected the account,
so it selected, you know,
the Larry Page account,
and then we got
the authentication cookie
from that, and that cookie
was created, you know,
when the user
actually registered
and tied it to his password.
So we just saw that, and then
we created the HTTP URL,
that is--
we're actually going to call,
and we initialize
the RequestFactory here
with that
AndroidRequestTransport,
which contains the cookie/
And that makes it sure
that when we do the HTTP query,
uh, we're actually going
to pass the cookie,
so that on the other hand,
the server actually knows
which user is actually
doing that request,
and that's where
the authentication comes in.
So we have that, uh,
factory here,
so now we're just
going to do, um--
so we need to get
the TaskRequest for it,
and then it's going
to look like--
exactly like the code
that Brad showed.
I'm just going to do
a query task, do a fire,
um, so the only thing that's
a little bit different here--
So the receiver is the--
The type is based
on the method,
and here, it's a list
of TaskProxy.
There we go.
Uh, and now--
there we go.
So that it--that's the method
that you need to implement.
There's other ones,
like on failure,
that you should
probably implement,
because if it doesn't work,
it throws a wrench on us again.
Abrams: We're not gonna have
any failures, though.
Ducrohet: We--no,
no failure today.
Um, all right, so here--
well, I have that list here
that I'm going to return later,
so I'm just going to add
the list of tasks that I get
to, uh, to my list--
so the point here is,
so right now, that act--
that fire,
that method that
Brad showed on the GWT client,
was, uh, asynchronous.
On Android right now
it's not asynchronous.
Uh, it's actually a bug.
It should be.
We're working on that.
Uh, so that's why I need to put
all of that into an asynctask,
so that we're sure that,
you know,
that doing by group method
is going to happen
automatically for you
in the background,
and then basically, that list
here is going to be passed
back to me
in the onPostExecute,
but that onPostExecute
is called from the UI thread,
and that's a very important
distinction.
And then here,
um, I'm going to...
I guess I need
to save that file here
and do some import, yes,
to make sure that it works.
There we go.
So I can go to a task--
and so activity addTask,
um, you know, all I do basically
is pass back to my list adapter,
give it the new
list of task,
and call notifyDataSetChanged,
which is going to refresh
my listView.
Those code must happen
on the UI thread,
which is why I do that
in the, uh, onPost background--
uh, onPostExecute method.
All right, uh,
I think I have everything.
Now, uh, we've recently
encountered a bug
into, uh, probably Eclipse,
so I'm just going to do
a clean view.
You haven't seen anything.
Abrams: Mm-hmm.
Ducrohet: Um, all right,
just to be sure,
and we're going to deploy that
to my emulator.
So that's crazy.
Oh, I forgot to show you, um,
when you create that project--
when that project is created
for you,
we do put some Java here,
like, the C2DM Java
is put there for you,
and also
the RequestFactory client.
This is the part that
deals with the RPC for you,
so it's all there for you. You
don't have to deal with that.
All right, so let's just
debug that
on my server--
on my, uh, emulator.
So, uh, as I showed,
as soon as the activity
is going to start,
there's going to be
a progress bar in the top right
that will show that
there's an RPC going on.
Maybe.
Oh, there it is.
Okay, waiting for debugger.
All right, so you see here
there's an RPC going on,
um, and so...
Abrams: So it's talking
from the emulator
to the App Engine service,
and it should find those tasks
that I added
via the GWT client.
Ducrohet: Yeah, and it's running
on the App Engine server,
running in Eclipse...
Abrams: Right.
Ducrohet: So you can put
breakpoint in that server, too.
You can put breakpoint
in the client.
You can really debug
both sides at once.
And there we go.
We have an RPC that happened.
So we have those three tasks,
and then if I click on them,
um, you see that which--
we have no task detail in there.
Abrams: That's beautiful.
So that is a nice-looking,
um, Android client,
but I-I think you should
give me a chance
to work on the GWT client
and make it equally nice.
Do you think--
we have a few minutes.
Ducrohet: You think?
Abrams: Yeah.
Ducrohet: All right.
Abrams: Okay, um, okay,
so let's get this Android stuff
out of the way here. Um...
Ducrohet: [laughs]
It's only fair,
I put his stuff out of the way
when I started.
Abrams: Yeah, okay,
so now we have a--
we have a-a few more files
to drag in here.
This is our fancy, uh--whoa.
This--this is a, uh,
Um, I hope I didn't
mess that up.
Okay, here--
here's our fancy GWT client,
um, we'll copy in,
and basically, we're
just using a UI binder
to make it a little nicer,
and then, um,
if you're a web developer,
and you're used to doing a lot
in CSS and HTML,
uh, that works really great
with GWT, as well.
You just put that stuff
in the WAR directory,
um, and that gets bundled
so it ships correctly.
Uh, and so with those in,
now we should be able
to switch to our client,
um, and refresh it.
So I--just notice, this is
running in DevMode,
um, but we don't have to stop
and restart the server,
so you can--you can
just keep refreshing
the browser
as you normally would.
So that's pretty nice.
So those are the tasks.
Um, and I think
what we should do
is I should go and add
another task, like, um,
How about,
Do I/O twice a year?
You think that's a good idea?
Something--yeah?
Ducrohet: Yeah.
Abrams: So we'll go ahead
and add that,
and you see the little
Android guy--okay.
Um, and then we look over,
and, you know,
Xavier, um, I added this task,
and I don't see it
showing up here or anything.
Ducrohet: Yes.
Abrams: I--you know what
I think you should do?
You should implement
some polling log.
You should, like, every few
seconds, you should ping
the App Engine server,
and then it'll tell you--
Ducrohet: You're not listening
when I'm talking.
That's what I said
we shouldn't do
at the beginning of the talk.
Abrams: Oh,
you shouldn't do that? No.
Okay, So what--
Ducrohet: Yes, you know,
the graph, C2DM?
Abrams: Oh, I remember that.
I remember that.
Ducrohet: That's what
you need to do.
Abrams: Oh, you want to do C2DM?
Ducrohet: Yes.
Abrams: So what you want
is when I add a new task,
you want me to send
a C2DM ping that you'll pick up?
Ducrohet: Yes.
Abrams: Okay, uh, luckily,
there's a nice place
to put business logic like that.
Uh, it's in the RequestFactory.
It's in--sorry, it's in
the CloudTasksService.
So basically, what he's saying
here is in update,
we need to send
the C2DM method.
So this is back
on the App Engine server
in the cloud service, um,
and Xavier's nervous
that I'll typo this,
um, so I better copy
and add on the snippets.
Um, so, uh,
let's just replace
this implementation with it.
Uh...
Ducrohet: So the only reason
we do that
is that there's
that particular myth out
where we need to first update
the datastore
to make sure that we get
the right I.D. once it's told,
'cause otherwise--
Abrams: Yes, it crashes.
It's bad things.
Ducrohet: Yeah, we've designed
a smart protocol here
that is very busy,
'cause you can see,
the message that we sent
is just--
so normally C2DM,
most applications
will only use it as a tickle,
just to basically poke
the app and say,
"You know, something happened.
Talk back to the server
to get more information."
Uh, but it--by C2DM, you can
actually send a small string--
Uh, I don't actually know
the limit,
but, you know,
you can send a small string,
so here, we're just sending
basically a keyword,
in that case, update, colon,
and the idea of the task
that we want.
Abrams: Yep. Yeah, so we
just made that small change,
exactly as Xavier described.
Um, and then we just need to
refresh the App Engine server,
so we leave the GWT client
as it is,
refresh the App Engine server
so it reloads with that--
with that new code.
And now what we should
be able to do
is go back
to our cloud task
and, let's see--
"Give all employees a raise."
I think that's a good--
good task.
And then let's bring up
the emulator here,
so you can see that worked.
So I'll just hit "Go" on that,
and then flip over here,
and there's the message,
and let's see if the I.D.--
there's an I.D. Okay, good.
So I think it's pretty good.
So we're sending
the C2DM message
from the App Engine server,
but, Xavier, you know,
that UI with just I.D., colon--
I don't think that's so hot.
Ducrohet: Yes, yes.
Abrams: You know, maybe
there's something you can do.
Ducrohet: All right,
so, um, here--
so normally, when you
build an application,
you are not going to do
what we're doing here,
which is basically go live
and request an RPC
every time the user
does something.
Uh, what you want really
is to have, like,
a local storage,
and have your task there.
Uh, not that you can't
receive a C2DM message
even when the user is not using
your application--
that's the whole point--
so what you should really--
really do is,
when you get a C2DM ping,
you should, like, you know,
launch a background service,
go query the new list
of tasks,
have some fancy protocol
so that you only get
really the one that happened.
So in our case, it's that...
[speaking indistinctly]
Uh, and then, you know,
put that on your storage,
and then your activity should
only go and query your storage.
All right, you shouldn't do--
like, here,
every time that activity
is displayed,
it goes and fetch back
the list of tasks,
and it's really not efficient,
so you shouldn't do that/
But for that talk, we didn't
want to go and, you know,
involve the storage,
so we just wanted to see
the basic... [speaking
indistinctly] mechanism happen.
So what you
are going to do here,
uh, to bypass that issue,
is we--what I did is,
that activity registers
itself as a listener
to the custom application
class that I did
when it's being displayed on--
and register itself
when it's being hidden,
so that's what we have in, um--
Uh, let me find, uh--
there we go.
Here. We'll just do that.
Uh, so in the--
there we go--
in the onResume,
I register my task
as a listener,
and here, I register it
as an onPost.
So what I need to do
is basically to call
that listener,
uh, from my C2DM receiver,
so that if the task--
if the activity is not showing,
then it's not going
to do anything,
and the message will be lost,
uh, which is okay.
So I mentioned that we had,
in the project that is created,
we have a class called
C2DM receiver.
Now that's a very basic class.
There's a lot of things going
in the background for you.
But basically,
there's this onMessage here,
and that's what happens--
that's what is called
when the C2DM tickle happened,
so you can ignore the rest.
All you have to do
is basically implement that,
which is exactly
what I'm going to do.
And that message display class
that is created here
is the, uh, notification thing,
you know,
you can throw that class away
once your--if you don't want it.
All right, so, um,
I'm going to get my application,
so it's
a taskApplication object,
and you can just call
getApplication.
It's just not our class
in the receiver.
Oh, I'm going to need
a cast here--there we go.
And then I'll do
my notifyListener.
And pass the intent--
that contains the content
of the C2DM.
So in that method here, um,
basically, if I have a listener,
then I have to do some work,
so I get that message
from the intent.
Um, and then I just do a split
on the column,
and send that to my listener,
which is my activity.
And that's what happens here.
Now as I mentioned earlier,
you can get that C2DM tickle--
you get it on a non-UI thread,
so if you want
to do some UI on it,
you have to use, uh,
run on your UI thread.
Uh, and I really do that,
because the asynctask needs to
be started from the UI thread.
So you're receiving
from the non-UI thread.
You go to UI thread
to start the asynctask,
which does the work
in the non-UI thread,
which sends the wizard
to the UI thread.
Abrams: Whew!
Ducrohet: Okay, so here
in my FetchTask,
uh, I had, you know,
planned for it,
so I have a long--
I have the I.D.
basically as a parameter,
so I--
and I pass it here
in the execute.
So I'm just going to change it
so that when we have a new task,
uh, we can just
go and fetch that one.
So, uh, it's going to be
pretty easy.
I have no arguments here,
so I'm just going to do--
if I have no arguments,
or if my arguments is--
by default, I said...
[speaking indistinctly]
fetch all,
so I'll do that.
And else, um--
I'm setting a flag
saying that it's just
a new task.
I'll explain that
in a minute.
And then I'll do another, um--
and so here it's readTask,
which is exactly
the same one that you had in--
that Brad showed
on the server,
and, uh, that's my argument.
There we go,
and then I need to do a fire,
which, uh,
should be asynchronous,
but as I said, isn't.
All right, and, uh, we send
the TaskProxy here,
and I implement my method.
There we go.
All right, and here,
that's pretty easy.
I still have my list.
What I have to do is do list.
add... [speaking indistinctly]
All right, and so at the end
of that execution here in the--
that's where I do--
I use my flag,
uh, that setTask--
actually, I showed you
addTask earlier,
but, uh, setTask here
sets the whole list,
and if I do "add,"
I just add to the existing.
And basically
in the "add after,"
I mean, all I have is really
just a list of tasks that--
and then I just sorted by date,
basically, so very easy.
All right, so, um,
let's make sure that everything
is saved here.
Okay, and it's saying disconnect
again--I'll work on it.
Abrams: [laughs]
Ducrohet: Um,
and let's just deploy that
as an Android application.
Ducrohet: So the first thing
that's going to happen
is that it's going
to restart my activity.
It's going to redo
that initial fetch,
where it's going
to get all the lists
of, uh, activities--
oh, of tasks.
Ducrohet: All right,
so same thing here.
So there's that, you know,
visual cue
that the RPC is going on.
Um,
when I'm going to enter
a new task,
you're going to see
that same visual cue,
so just look at it
when I hit "Enter."
So we need a new task--um,
oh, yeah, there we go.
All right, let's just wait
for that to finish.
So there's still--you know,
it's debugging--
the debuggers are connected
to both the server
and the front end, uh,
it's going through the emulator.
That's not exactly
the fastest thing these days,
so, you know, that's why the RPC
takes a little bit of time.
All right, so we have our task.
I'm going to hit "Enter,"
and there we go.
The C2DM was received,
and then automatically,
we do the FetchTask,
and it's right there.
We just refreshed it.
Abrams: Yeah, so that is
very good.
[applause]
Abrams: That is very cool.
Just to recap--so, you know,
a few of you that were clapping
really got what was happening,
and for those of you
that weren't clapping,
I'm gonna explain it to you
so that you can--no...
Um, so it's really--it's really
impressive what was going on.
So he--from the AJAX client,
typed in a new task,
hit "Return."
Uh, that animated the cool
little Android thing,
um, and then--
and then it did
an RPC call to the server,
stored that item in
the highly scalable datastore,
and then when that came back,
it sent a C2DM ping,
um, to a Google service,
which then remoted it back down
to the phone.
The phone got the ping
with an I.D. in it,
like, was it 7 or something?
Uh, 7, and then--
and then he got that 7,
and then he said, "Oh,
I'm gonna go do an RPC call,
and find task
with the I.D. 7."
And then he did an RPC call
back to the App Engine server,
got that task, um,
and brang it down to the client
and displayed it,
so it was very cool.
Um, I think we're--
I think it's pretty good.
I think at this point,
we're ready for them to use it,
don't you think?
Ducrohet: Sure, yes.
Abrams: I think we should just
deploy it to App Engine,
so let's talk about how we do
that deployment.
So, um, what do we do?
Uh, we go into "setup."
Um, so there's one--
one little thing.
You go into "setup," uh,
and you need to change this
to match your App Engine I.D.--
whatever--you can go to App
Engine and register a free I.D.
You have to be somewhat
creative with the names.
Um, Sean's working on that--
Uh, but right now, it's, uh,
you have to be fairly creative
to find a unique name.
Um, and then you just--whoops--
uh, you can't deploy, actually--
yeah, you just--
Ducrohet: It doesn't type, also.
Abrams: Where is it?
Ducrohet:
Just Android--andriade.
Abrams: Oh, yeah.
We don't want to deploy
to the wrong place.
Um, and then
we don't deploy the Android
application to App Engine.
We have to go to
the App Engine application.
Um, you just click this cool
little icon here, um,
and then in here,
you give it the same I.D.
Um, hopefully I typed it right--
and then the cool thing is,
you can use any version.
So I'm gonna use the version
"staging" right now,
'cause I'm gonna get it up there
and test it out
before I flip over
and have everybody use it.
Um, and then we just
click "Okay,"
uh, and "Deploy."
And now what's gonna happen
is it's going to build
a highly optimized version
of the GWT client for--
for many permutations
of languages and browsers,
so that each browser
gets exactly
the minimum
JavaScript they need.
Um, and so while that's going--
and then it's gonna
upload it to App Engine
and verify it's there,
and you'll get a URL back.
While that's going on, though,
we already have one deployed,
uh, ahead of time,
kind of Julia Child style,
um, up there,
and we have it installed
on these phones,
so why don't you switch over
to the thing?
Ducrohet: All right, so, uh,
we have two phones here,
so I'm going to add a task
to that one.
Um...
Well, I'm not going to type
a whole lot on here.
Um, there.
"Save."
So here you can see also,
there's the RPC
that's actually sending
this time,
uh, and then actually--
or, querying.
It just did--
okay, it's there already.
Um,
it should happen
on the other one.
Oh, it's on WiFi.
[laughs]
Abrams: Oh, yes. We have--
we might have a WiFi--
We need everyone to get on--
No, I'm joking.
Um, well, maybe it'll--
maybe it'll show up.
that one--
Ducrohet: Yeah. Okay.
Abrams: Okay, so we have it--
we have it on one.
Do you want to add--
Ducrohet: Okay, yes.
Abrams: Yeah, so let's
switch over to this one,
to the Mac,
and so we have
the exact same client.
Um, and you'll see--
I think we'll see,
in just a second--
um, that he--
we got the exact same task here.
So, um, if you add
another task there,
and just tell us
when you hit "Go" there,
so we can see how quickly--
and you see,
I'm not touching it, so I'm not
gonna refresh the browser.
This is one of the benefits
you get from Request--
using RequestFactory in GWT,
is that as soon as--
Ducrohet: Are you ready?
Abrams: Yeah.
Ducrohet: One, two, three.
Abrams: Three, okay, so it sent
it up to the App Engine server,
and then back down,
and there it is--again.
Um, so that's very cool.
[applause]
Abrams: [speaking indistinctly]
Ducrohet:
[speaking indistinctly]
Abrams: Okay.
Okay, so I think we'll--
Ducrohet: Let--let's do it
the other way.
Abrams: Oh, you're gonna do it
the other way. Okay, yeah.
Ducrohet: So I-I'll switch back
to that one.
Abrams: Uh, you know,
what's something that needs
to be on Larry's task list?
What should we add
on Larry's task list?
I need a--
man: [speaking indistinctly]
Abrams: [chuckles]
Oh, yeah--
better WiFi
at I/O next year.
Ducrohet: Yes,
that should be good.
Abrams: Okay, so now I'll
do that. I've--I've sent it.
Ducrohet: There you go. You've
got the notification already,
and there it is.
Abrams: Yeah. So...
[applause]
Abrams: Awesome.
Ducrohet: Okay, very good.
Abrams: Okay,
so that was the demo,
um, so just the summary
of what you saw.
Uh, we think that
as an Android developer,
you can increase
your customer's love
by building cloud-connected
Android applications.
We think App Engine is
a really fantastic technology
to go use for that,
and we hope that this beta
of GPE 2.4, uh,
makes it very easy
to go do that.
Now I imagine some of you might
want to play with this project,
so it's available live
right now--
the exact, uh, one we were
just running over here--
if you go to
the running application,
cloudtaskio.appspot,
and we can test the scalability
of App Engine right now,
um, by all of you
going to that.
Um, all of the source code
that we typed in,
this full project,
is available for you
at the code site there--
cloudtasksio.
Um, and then I thought
it was very cool--
the top project is just
the starter project,
just showing you C2DM working
and the RPC working.
Uh, that's available for you
to play with on your phone
at that top URL.
Then, um, hopefully, this
gave you just a little taste
for things, so Android
sessions--do you want to--
Ducrohet: Yeah. So, uh, first,
if you want to go and download
the Android developer tools,
it's on developer.android.com,
and we have, uh,
two other sessions--
the "Android Developer Tools"
is tomorrow afternoon
in room 11 at 3:00.
The "Best Practice"--I don't
actually know when that is.
Abrams: I can't remember.
I think it already happened,
actually, so you might have
to YouTube it to get there.
Ducrohet: Oh, okay.
Abrams: And then the App Engine
and GP--
a number of great sessions,
um, that, uh--
go to, uh,
Google code appengine.
Um, you can find all kinds
of good data on it.
Um, a couple of good sessions
to go check out--
the "Bringing the Cloud
to Your IDE."
If you want to hear more about
things we've done with GPE,
that's a good place
to go look, um,
and then "Scaling App Engine
Applications,"
because I know
your Android app cases
will just be fantastically big--
huge, I mean, successful.
Um, okay, and then, uh, we--
one thing I wanted to stress,
um, I'll put it back--
Uh, one thing I wanted to stress
is we really need
your feedback on this.
We're very early.
Uh, this is a very raw state,
uh, for GPE 2.4.
We want you to go build
some apps and give us feedback
so we know what we need to do
to polish it up
and finish it off, so...
Ducrohet: And then we have
five minutes for questions.
Abrams: Yes, and we have five
minutes for questions, so...
Ducrohet: So there's
two mics there, so...
Abrams: Any quest--
it was perfectly clear?
man: Hi, I have a question
for you.
Abrams: Where are we?
Over there.
man: For...
[applause]
man: For the RPC service
that you're providing here,
how are you serializing
the data?
Are you using proto buffers,
JSON objects?
Abrams: Yes, uh,
it's serialized as JSON--
I don't know the techn--
somebody's gonna help me out
in the front row? [chuckles]
It serializes it as JSON...
man: Okay.
Abrams: And I don't know
what technology it's using,
but you can find that out.
man: Okay, no. Thank you.
Abrams: Anyone got a--
Whoops, over there.
man: You showed us how to create
an app from scratch
using all the generated code.
What about taking
an existing app and adding
App Engine functionality
as an added feature to it?
How do you utilize
all that generated code
without having to start
from scratch on your project,
importing all your old code?
Abrams: Yeah, I-I think
the project structure
we're using in Eclipse is a--
I--we did a lot
of really good work,
but it's not
rocket science work,
and so you should be able
to kind of go and see
how we did the link folders,
and whatnot, to make it--
to make sure the tooling wizards
and stuff will work.
Ducrohet: Yeah, I mean,
the only diff--
the only hard part
is the shared folder,
which is easy to replicate,
but, yeah,
you could definitely
just create a new project
and then just drop your current
Android application
or App Engine in there.
I mean, it's--you know,
that's the first
very rough version.
Uh, definitely it's one thing
that we need to improve
in the future,
and have, you know,
better things to work on
for existing projects.
man: Okay, thank you.
Abrams: Cool.
man: Uh, you showed, uh, Java
Google App Engine
implementation.
Do you have a sample code
or something
for a Python-based?
Abrams: Uh, no--so, yes--
So App Engine supports Python
just as well as it does Java.
We--we chose to build
the tooling in Eclipse
up around Java,
um, because it's just
more common,
same language,
you know, on both sides,
Um, the same basic system
will work.
Uh, we don't have
the RequestFactory framework
for Python yet, but that's, uh,
I mean, if that's something
people are interested in,
it's good--
really good feedback.
man: Okay, thank you.
man: Is there anything
special we need to do
with the Android project to make
it compatible with Proguard?
Ducrohet: Um... that's actually
a good question.
Uh, there's probably--
yeah, you're probably
going to have to make sure
that all the classes,
like the TaskProxy,
and all of that
that are generated
do not get renamed
by Proguard.
man: Mm-hmm.
Ducrohet: Um, that's--
yeah, that--
I mean, at first, you're going
to have to do that manually.
It's definitely something
that we'll have to think about
to maybe integrate into
the, uh, like the RPC tooling,
so that it automatically add
to the Proguard file,
but right now, that's not...
[speaking indistinctly]
It's a very rough version.
man: Okay, thank you.
Ducrohet: But it's--
it's a very good feedback.
man: Um, you showed GWT--you
don't actually need to refresh
to get the task updated.
Abrams: Mm-hmm.
man: What technology are you
using for that?
Are you using long polling?
Are you using the channel API
that's built into App Engine?
How are you doing the push
request from the server?
Abrams: Yeah, uh, I believe
it's doing long polling.
It's using RequestFactory
functionality that's been in--
Is Chris giving me the answer?
No. [chuckles]
It's been in for--
man: [speaking indistinctly]
Abrams: Yeah. Yeah, so I believe
it's doing long polling.
man: Is there any, um,
plans to support
the channel API in the future,
or is that not really
where GWT is headed?
Abrams: Chris, do you want
to help me?
Chris: This actually came up
in the fireside chat today.
We, uh...
Abrams: Go--go to the mic.
Go to the mic.
So Chris is the PM for GWT.
Chris: Hey, how's it going?
Hey, great demo.
Yeah, that actually came up
in the fireside chat today,
and we're--we've had a couple
teams messing with it,
and trying it out, and, uh--
so, yeah, we're looking into it.
Nothing on...
[speaking indistinctly]
Abrams: Okay, thanks.
man: [speaking indistinctly]
Abrams: Okay, yeah.
man: I have a quick comment
for Chris--
He should use this as part
of a sample application.
This is better-looking than what
you have in GWT showcases.
[laughter]
man: And, uh, second thing is,
uh, this won't work
with remote service, right?
This is for RequestFactory,
so we'll have
to put RequestFactory?
Abrams: Yeah,
this is RequestFactory.
man: Okay, thank you.
Abrams: Yeah, we had
a lot of debates about it,
but decided to go
to RequestFactory.
man: That's fine, thank you.
Abrams: Okay, yep,
last--last question--
man: You generate
a lot of code.
Is there any plans of putting
that in the framework instead?
Abrams: Yes, again, something
we're debating a lot--
we did actually put some code
already for C2DM
in the framework.
Um, we felt a little weird
about putting code
in a framework
that writes directly
to DataStore, for example,
because you might want to use
a different store.
Um, but it's a balance that
we're going back and forth on.
I think we erred this time
a little bit more
onto the generated code
than on the framework,
but that's an area where we're
really looking for feedback,
so jump on the forums
and give us some feedback.
Speaking of which, um,
uh, we would--we would really
love your feedback
on the session, as well--
Um, you can--you can tweet here,
and I believe that code takes
you to the feedback forum.
man: Okay, and you can use that
also from the, uh, Google app,
you can go to find that link.
Abrams: Yep.
Yeah, and so one of us
has to buy drinks
for the other
based on your feedback,
so please--please put that in.
Ducrohet: [laughs]
Adams: Okay, and we'll be around
here for questions,
uh, if you want to just come up,
or in the Android booth.
man: Great.
Abrams: So thanks.
Ducrohet: Thank you very much.